olá bom dia ouvi dizer a marta que vocês
queriam ser famosos hoje minha vez de
ser famosa tem um microfone da shakira
segundo disseram é você shantou de
ilustres vencedores por isso é um prazer
estar aqui para vos contar uma história
e esta história é uma história de amor
uma história de amor é assim como os
filmes começou há muitos muitos anos ea
minha história de amor com o mar
é tudo com ouro branco onde se lia
cheiro e shayk sítio ideal para mexer
era o mar
a minha mãe estava na praia muito vai
verão calor e eu pensei ok é que no
oceano como quem dê sorte ela conseguiu
tirar o aol hospital e eu não nasci no
mar mas deixe pernas muito perto x cuba
é parte de sempre verão praia sempre na
água é ter a primeira vez que mergulhar
e é a primeira vez que mergulhei eu
tinha 6 anos
isto é com garrafas rotina e foi uma
experiência incrível claro o meu pai
dava curso de mergulho e eu sempre segui
para todo lado e eu acho que não sabia
ler nem escrever e já ouvia falar física
do mergulho imaginem só
claro que tive que tirar o meu tempo e
aos 16 anos tirei o curso foi fantástico
estar debaixo d'água e ser uma
verdadeira paixão dentro da água estava
ali eu mesmo a perder um número este
país fantástico e foi por causa de eu
que estou aqui hoje
pensai quando o cheiro eu vou ter de
fazer alguma coisa relacionada com o mar
tem que ser eu tenho que trabalhar com o
mar ia ser peixeira
era uma profissão podia ser nadadora
salvadora e genival boa conheci ele
marinheira num bar qualquer podia vender
bônus menina praia só para sentir o
cheiro da maresia todos os dias mas não
pensa em coisas mais concretas pelo
jeito de ser
investigadora usuário é terapeuta
infantil mirim e descobrir o que eu faço
para arranjar uma namorada e tatu também
deu podia perceber porque é que os
pinguins não tem frio nas patas
e andar no bairro colônia de pinguins
com os pingüins todos atrás de mim como
se eu própria fosse um pinguim
imagino se camadas e camadas de roupa
para resistir a 90 graus negativos
consegue imaginar 90 graus negativos
viver meses e mesmo à tarde a estudar
como é que por exemplo o aquecimento do
planeta é feita estes animais e ficar
certamente conhecida como a protetora
dos pingüins quem estava de ser a
estréia do popular ao ambiente deve ser
investigado há muito bem lá atrás duas
pessoas foi a menina que a frente não
pensarão o mesmo que eu pensei viver
mesmo na tarde né
e significa a 6 o bahia sem só ficou
mesmo genta eu acho que o time disseram
não fez pensar não eo pior tudo querer
comer um chocolate e eu estar tão duro
tão duro por causa do frio de quase
partiu um dente campus party essa ideia
mas que está idéia está próximo de
singles dos albatrozes focas tirar uma
fotografia um tem uma fotografia a outro
terá uma fotografia um tubarão balaia e
ser fotógrafa fotografia subaquática
parece muito vai tirar uma fotografia
também aqui o tubarão
naquele momento com o pisca o olho e deu
enormes riscos mas eu não sei só pessoa
mesmo que os estava a criar uma trinca
mas ser os olhos de todas as pessoas que
não podem mergulhar a e quem não tenha
opinado que seria esse mais ele era uma
experiência fantástica está a mergulhar
por exemplo que tirar uma fotografia é
um cachorro lote e eu querer mudar é uma
trilha com a cabeça
imaginam um trecho da nota que recebeu
são 1 234 metros que teve sempre
cachalote
além disso os mandantes não quem estava
ser fotógrafo subaquático e não é muita
gente e muitos fotógrafos silva 41
eu também achei um sismo a princípio mas
depois comecei a pensar até uma máquina
duas máquinas por fácil ou flash três
estados quatro casos sem filtros 4
não não é pra mim dá conta de trabalhar
atrás não tem no baianão do país
sinceramente não dou mais uma vez gostei
da idéia é descobrir animais que nunca
ninguém tinha visto esse eu em vez de um
animal descobri uma história uma
história de há muito tempo atrás se eu
fosse ao mar procurar alguma coisa que
alguém tinha deixado mp3 contar é todo
mundo o que tinha acontecido e comer
comer se considerava comadre encontrar
por exemplo uma colher de café de um
raio qualquer encontrar um gancho no
capitão com mau feitio e saber o que tem
acontecido conhecer para que o ganso
prática parece uma boa ideia que gostava
de ser o que ela é muito dizer que o
estilo quati cruz querem dar a mergulhar
eu também estava a andar a mudar mas sim
um problema
sou alérgico a pó já sei que vão dizer
que uma pode bastar água mas pelo sim
pelo não achei que era melhor não ter
nessas aventuras mas que estava de
aventuras boa ideia e estava muitos dos
golfinhos que gosta de golfinhos atores
são como eu muito vai e eu também gosto
imenso no fim som e achei que andará
vingou fins era o ideal é andar a ver
com o fim sérgio china mas precisa de
mais alguma coisa mas alguma coisa não
só ver golfinhos então ver golfinhos
embarcava num barco de pesca de tudo já
ouviram falar em observadores pesca tem
se em já observei dois pés que são
pessoas que estão nos barcos aprender um
pouquinho como é que os pescadores que
deus faz é esse sinal também é o mais
importante é garantir que eles não
percam nem golfinhos na interligas
marinhas nem baías e isso é uma coisa
muito importantes porque não basta
lançar o anzol
não basta mesmo é preciso perceber quem
é que mora o risco aí alto-mar grandes
ondas e oliver os dolphins o capitão a
gritar é
a bordo fez o lote e eu ia correr
fantástico quem estava de ser observador
e ver golfinhos todos os dias
aquela menina por tamanho e têm som das
ondas grandes disse polícia não ondas
grandes não eu ia passar o tempo todas
militar em vias de golfinhos não ia ver
nada e só ver a casa do arco mexe também
vive com toda a sinceridade eu não tenho
medo de aceitar desafios e chay onde
existem onde só cai eu estou lá e então
podia fazer qualquer coisa relacionada
com um desporto um desporto conhecer a
professora por cima uma boa profissão
emendou escritório para trabalhar ir pra
praia de chinelos não ter horários levar
a dores que minha cadela para o trabalho
ninguém se chatear e mais tudo podia
ensinar ninguém da sociedade é não ter
medo das ondas também era giro vai
imagina o entusiasmo de que o menino que
punem p
nessa sua prancha pela primeira vez vai
brutal aposta monte de gente que sempre
surfo quem quer sempre surf muito muito
bem que me tem de ser vista e tudo sinto
ser vista que o menino era uma ideia
pois é dentro da água onde chegam pra vc
ondas espera olha a onda só sete ondas
que sentirá olha a onda numa onda
faltava aqui ação ação ação é o que
precisa agora vai rural chato petróleo
vamos lá limpar e central ou então um
golfinho preso numa queda como é que o
centro será que podemos ajudar não
podemos ajudar mais uma tartaruga que
engoliu um anzol
é preciso retiraram alguma pinça tirar
tratar fazer raio-x e depois do vala de
volta a casa poderia ser veterinária mas
não treinaria de cães nem de gatos não
gosta demais de uma média com dor de
cabeça
se treinar etária estar lá no momento
salvar a ajudar
isso era mesmo muito importante quem
estava de se treinar you muitos esta
menina aqui muito vai treinar área muito
bem eu sou nenhum problema
não sei se o time todo está aí é que eu
não posso ver sangue era importante sim
senhora baixo sangue pra mim não dá o
primeiro animal uma parceria uma pata
prática e sanga ver pronto eu desenhava
e não conhecer a verdade é que eu não
fui nenhuma destas coisas
fui bióloga marinha e acabei por
conseguir fazer alguma coisa que fizesse
alguém estar tanto do mar como eu e eu
acho que tive mesmo muita sorte por um
dia cheguei em um grande aquário que é o
cenário que esperava se esqueça da onde
trabalho é é minha sorte é que recebi
todos todos os dias - das cidades mais
clientes mais crescidos e e tv lotes e
todos os dias diz posso ensinar um
pesinho sobre os oceanos desvendar os
segredos em verdadeiras expedições pelos
pelas teorias pelos aquário cultura
diversidade que ela existe posso ensinar
por exemplo a história de um tubarão não
queria ser tubarão porque todos tinham
medo eu posso contar as viagens
fantásticas das tartarugas marinhas
importantes mas posso contar outras
coisas possam explicar diz que os
oceanos cobrem 70% do planeta e que 90 e
107 por cento de toda a vida viveu nos
oceanos se calhar como também disseram
há pouco faria mais sentido chamado de
planeta oceano do planeta terra também
poderia dizer que tudo que nós sons e
razão de nós existimos se deva aos
oceanos porque os fornecem 70% do
oxigênio o ar que respiramos que nos dão
alimentos que são muito muito
importantes no ciclo da água ea água é
fundamental e também porque regula a
temperatura do planeta em oceanos
não poderia existir já pensaram nisso já
pensaram no planeta sem oceano como é
que seria consegue pensar imaginar o que
seria se fosse a é difícil imaginar que
eu acho que é impossível de imaginar e
apesar de tudo a importância que o
paciente está em que imensa para nós
estamos sujeitos a imenso as ameaças
escalar vocês já ouviram falar de
algumas como sobre pesca à poluição por
exemplo derrames de petróleo ou os
plásticos é o aquecimento do planeta
tudo isto afeta os oceanos e quem sabe
nós estamos a comprometer o futuro dos
oceanos e talvez nós próprios mas a
outra coisa é outra coisa que eu posso
dizer estes meninos e vocês também é que
existe uma esperança e essa expressa
está neles está em vocês o meu desejo
sincero mesmo sincero é que vocês possam
gostar tanto do mar como eu e que se
envolvam e que façam alguma coisa e que
seja quando preencherem sejam
cozinheiros sejam advogados medo de que
os professores houve outros meios tanto
faz que façam alguma coisa por este
grande azul que é o oceano
isso é o que eu faço todos os dias é dar
um carrinho do meu coração pelo oceano e
fazer com que os outros gostem deu tanto
como eu
obrigada